the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today we are going to continue
looking at critical points and we'll
learn how to actually decide whether
physical point is a minimum and maximum
our saddle point
so let's remain topic for today so
remember yesterday we looked at critical
points of functions of several variables
and so a physical point of the function
C of two variables x and y that's the
point that's a point where the partial
derivatives are both zero and we've seen
that there's various kinds of critical
points first local minima so maybe I
should show the function and its contour
plot there's local Maxima which are like
that and there's saddle points which are
neither minima or Maxima and of course
if you have a real function then it may
be it will be more complicated it will
have several ethical points so this
example here well you see on the plot
that verse two Maxima and there's in the
middle between them there's a saddle
point and actually you can see them on
the contour plots on the contour plot
you see the Maxima because the level
curves become circles that narrow down
and shrink to the maximum and you can
see the saddle point because here you
have this level curve that makes a
figure 8 it closes itself and if you
move up or down here then so along the Y
direction the values of the function
will decrease along the X direction the
values will increase so you can
see usually quite easily where are the
critical points just by looking either
at the graph or at the contour plot so
the only thing with the contour plot is
you need to locate the values to tell a
minimum from a maximum because the
contour plots look the same just of
course in one case the values increase
in paper one we decrease so the question
is how do we decide between the various
possibilities so the local minimum local
maximum or saddle point
so and in fact why do we care
well the other question is how do we
find the global minimum or maximum of a
function so here already I should point
out well first of all you know to decide
where the function is the largest in
general you'll have actually to compare
the values for example here if you want
to know what is the maximum of this
function well we have two obvious
candidates we have this local maximum
and that local maximum and the question
is which one is where high over two well
in this case actually they're exactly
tied for maximum but in general you
would have to compute the function at
both points and compare the values if
you know that it's free at one of them
and for the other well four wins the
other thing that you see here is if
you're looking for a minimum of this
function well the minimum is not going
to be at any of the critical points so
where's the minimum well it looks like
the minimum is actually out there on the
boundary or at infinity so that's
another feature of a global minimum or
maximum doesn't have to be at a critical
point it could also be somehow on the
side you know in some limiting situation
where one variable stops being in the
allowed range of values or goes to
infinity so we have to actually check
the boundary and the Infinity behavior
of our function to know where actually
the minimum and maximum will be so in
general should point out this could
occur either at the critical point
Oh on the boundary or at infinity so by
that I mean on the boundary of a domain
of definition that we are considering
and so we have to try both okay
but so we'll get back to that for now
let's try to focus on the question of
what's the type of the critical point
so we'll use something that's known as
the second derivative test and in
principle well the idea is kind of
similar to what you do with a function
of one variable namely function of one
variable if the derivative is zero then
you know that you should look at the
second derivative and that will tell you
whether it's curving up or down whether
you have a local max and the local min
and the main problem here is of course
we have more possible situations and we
have several derivatives so actually we
have to think a bit harder about how we
decide but it will again involve the
second derivatives okay so let's start
with just an easy example that will be
useful to us because actually it will
provide the basis for the general method
okay so we are first going to consider a
case where we have a function that's
actually just quadratic so let's say i
have a function w of x y let's of the
form ax squared plus BX y plus CY
squared okay so this guy has a critical
point at the origin right because if you
take the derivative with respect to X
well and if you plug x equals y equals
zero you'll get zero and same with
respect to Y you can also see if you try
to do a linear approximation of this
well all these guys are much smaller
than x and y when x and y are small so
the linear approximation the tangent
plane to the graph is ready just W
equals zero okay so how do we do it
well yesterday which we did an example
it was a bit more complicated than bad
but let me do it so remember we are
looking at something that started with x
squared plus 2xy plus y plus 3y squared
and there were other terms but let's
forget them now and what we did is we
said well we can rewrite this
x plus y squared plus 2y squared and now
this is a sum of two squares so each of
these guys has to be non-negative and so
the origin will be a minimum well turns
out we can do something similar in
general no matter what these values of a
B and C are we'll just try to first
complete things to a square okay so
let's do that so in general well let me
be slightly less general and let me
assume that a is nonzero because
otherwise I can't do what I'm going to
do so I'm going to write this as a times
x squared plus B over a X Y then I have
my C Y squared and now this looks like
the beginning of the square of something
just like what we did over there so what
is it the square of well you'd start
with X plus and claim if I put B over 2a
times y and I square then C the term the
custom two times x times B over 2a Y
will become B over a X Y of course now I
certain I also get some Y squares out of
this how many Y squares do I get when I
get B squared over 4a squared times a so
I get B squared over 4a y squared so and
I want in fact C times y squared so the
number of Y squared I should add is C
minus B squared over 4a okay let's see
that again if I expand this thing I will
get a x squared plus a times B over 2a
times 2xy that's going to be maybe XY
but I also get B
squared over 4a squared y squared times
a that's B squared over 4a y squared and
that cancels out with this guy here and
then I will be left with C Y squared
okay do you see it kinda okay if not
well try expanding this square again
maybe I'll do it just to convince you
but so if I expand this I will get a
times let me put that in a different
color because you shouldn't write that
down it's just to convince you again so
if you don't see it yet let's expand
this thing we'll get a times x squared
plus a times 2x B over 2a Y well the two
aids cancel out we get B XY plus a times
the square of that that's going to be B
squared over 4a squared Y squared plus C
y squared minus B squared over 4a y
squared here the a and the a simplifies
and now these two terms simplify and
give me just C Y squared in the end okay
and that's kind of unavailable after
I've cancelled everything but if you
follow it you see that basically I've
just rewritten my initial function okay
is that kind of okay I mean otherwise
that's just no substitute to you know
you have you'll have to do it yourself
I'm afraid okay so let me continue to
play with this so I'm just going to put
this in a slightly different form just
to clear the denominators okay so I will
write this as 1 over 4a times a big
thing so I'm going to just put 4 a
squared times X plus B over 2a y squared
ok so so far I have the same thing as
here ok I just introduced a 4a that
cancels out plus 4 the other one I'm
just clearing the denominator I end up
with 4ac minus b squared y squared ok so
that's a lot of terms but what does it
look like well it looks like so we have
some constant factors and here we have a
square and here we have a squared a
square so basically we've written this
as a sum of two squares well a sum or
difference of two squares and maybe
that's what we need to figure out to
know what kind of point it is because
see if you take a sum of two squares
then you'll know that each square takes
non-negative values and you'll have the
total you know the function will always
take non-negative values so the origin
will be a minimum well if you have a
difference of two squares then typically
you'll have a saddle point because
depending on whether one of the other is
larger and you'll have a positive or a
negative quantity okay so I claim
there's various cases to look at so
let's see
so in fact I claim there will be three
cases and that's good news for us
because after all we want to distinguish
between three possibilities so let's
first do away with the most complicated
one
what if for AC minus B squared is
negative well if it's negative then it
means what I have between the brackets
is so the first guy is all obviously a
positive quantity while the second one
will be something negative times y
squared so it will be a negative
quantity okay so one term is positive
the other is negative that tells us we
actually have a saddle point we have in
fact writing our function as a
difference of two squares ok is that
convincing so if you want I could do
what I could do is actually I could
change my coordinates have new
coordinates call u equals x plus B over
2a Y and V actually what I could keep Y
and then it would look like a difference
of squares directly ok so that's the
first case the second case is where 4ac
minus b squared equals 0 well what
happens if that's 0 then it means that
this term of a pair goes away so what we
have is just one square okay so what
that means is actually that our function
depends only on one direction of things
in the other direction it's going to
actually be degenerate so for example
forget all the clutter in there say I
give you just the function
two variables w equals just x squared so
that means it doesn't depend on Y at all
and if I try to plot the graph it will
look well so X is here so it will depend
on X in that way but it doesn't depend
on Y at all so what we have looks like
is something like that okay it's
basically it's a valley whose bottom is
completely flat so that means actually
we have a degenerate critical point it's
called degenerate because there's a
direction in which nothing happens and
in fact you have critical points
everywhere along the y axis okay so now
whether the square that we have is x or
something else namely X plus B over 2a y
it doesn't matter I mean it will still
get this degenerate behavior that
there's a direction in which nothing
happens because we just have the square
of one quantity
I'm sure that 300 students means 300
different ringtones but I'm not eager to
hear all of them
thanks okay so this is what's called the
degenerate vertical point and okay so
basically we'll leave it here we won't
actually try to figure out further what
happens and the reason for that is that
when you have an actual function a
general function not just one that's
quadratic like this then there will
actually be other terms maybe involving
higher powers
you know maybe X cubed or Y cubed or
things like that and then they will mess
up what happens in this valley and it's
a situation where we won't be able
actually to tell automatically just by
looking at second derivatives what
happens see for example in a function of
one variable if you have just a function
of one variable say f of X equals x to
the 5 well if you try to decide what
type of point the origin is you know
you're going to take the second
derivative it will be zero and then you
can conclude because things depend on
higher order derivatives so we just
won't like that case we just want try to
figure out what's going on here now the
last situation is if 4ac minus b squared
is positive so then that means that
actually we've written things the the
big bucket up there is a sum of two
squares okay so
that means that we've written W as one
of our 4a x plus something squared plus
something else squared okay so these
guys have the same sign and that means
that this term here will always be
greater or equal to zero and so that
means that we should have either a
maximum or a minimum how do we decide
which one it is well we look at the sign
of a exactly okay so there's two sub
cases one is if a is positive then this
quantity overall will always be
non-negative and that means we have a
minimum okay and if a is negative on the
other hand so that means that we
multiply this positive quantity by a
negative number we get something that's
always negative so zero is actually the
maximum okay
is that clear for everyone yes
sorry so yeah I said now I said in the
example w equals x square it doesn't
depend on Y if I have so the marginal
situation is w equals some constant well
I guess it's a times X plus B over 2a
and y squared so it does depend on x and
y but it only depends on this
combination okay so if I choose to move
in somehow the perpendicular direction
in the direction where this remains
constant so maybe if I set x equals
minus B over 2a Y then this remains 0
all the time so there's a degenerate
direction in which I stay at the minimum
or maximum or whatever it is that I have
okay so that's why it's called
degenerate there's a direction in which
nothing happens okay yes
yes yeah yeah so that's a very good
question so I say there's going to be
the second derivative test why do we not
have derivatives yet well that's because
I've been looking at this special
example where we have a function like
this and so I don't actually need to
take derivatives yet but that's secretly
that's because a B and C will be the
second derivatives of a function
actually to a b and to C so now we are
going to go to a general function and
there instead of having these
coefficients a B and C given to us we'll
have to compute them as second
derivatives okay so here I'm basically
setting the stage for what will be the
actual criterion we'll use using second
derivatives yes so yeah so when you have
a degenerate critical point it could be
a degenerate minimum or a degenerate
maximum depending on the sign of a but
in general once you start having more
complicated functions you don't really
know what will happen anymore it could
also be a degenerate saddle and so on so
we won't really be able to tell yes it
is possible to have a degenerate saddle
point for example if I give you X cubed
plus y cubed you can convince yourself
that if you take x and y to be negative
it will be negative if x and y are
positive it's positive and it has a very
degenerate critical point at the origin
so that's a degenerate saddle point we
don't see it here because that doesn't
happen if you have only quadratic terms
like that you need to have higher order
terms to see it happen okay
so
okay so let's continue Oh before we
continue let's see I wanted to point out
one small thing so here we have this
magic quantity for AC minus B squared
you've probably seen that before in your
life yeah it looks like the quadratic
formula except that one involves b
square minus 4ac but that's really the
same thing okay so let's see where does
the poetic formula come in here well let
me write things differently
okay so we've manipulated things and
gotten to a conclusion but let me just
do a different manipulation and write
this now instead of Y squared times a
times X over Y squared plus B X over Y
plus C okay see that's the same thing
that I had before all right well so now
this quantity here is always
non-negative what about this one well of
course this one depends on x over y
means it depends on which direction
you're going to move away from the
origin which ratio between x and y you
will consider but I claim there's two
situations one is so let's try to
reformulate things so if the
discriminant here is positive then it
means that this has a roots like this
has solutions
and that means that this quantity can be
both positive and negative this quantity
takes positive and negative values one
way to convince yourself it's just to
you know plot a t square plus BT plus C
you know that there's two holes so it
might look like this or it might look
like that depending on the sign of a but
in either case it will take values of
both sides so that means that your
function will take values of both sides
W takes both positive and negative
values and so that means we have a
saddle point while the other situation
when b squared minus 4ac is negative
means that this equation is quadratic
never takes the value zero so it's
always positive or it's always negative
depending on the sign of a the other
case is if b square minus 4ac is
negative then the quadratic doesn't have
a solution and it could look like this
or like that depending on whether a is
positive or a is negative so in
particular that means a X over Y squared
plus B X over Y plus C is always
positive or always negative depending on
the sign of a and then that tells us
that our function W will be always
positive or always negative and then
we'll get a minimum or a maximum
it will have a min or max depending on
which situation we are in okay so that's
another way to derive the same answer
and now here you see why the
discriminant plays a role that's because
it exactly tells you whether this
quadratic quantity has always the same
sign or whether I can actually cause the
value zero when you have a root of a
quadratic okay so hopefully at this
stage you are happy with one of the two
explanations at least and now you're
willing to believe I hope that we have
basically a way of deciding what type of
critical point we have in the special
case of a quadratic function
okay so now what do we do with a general
function well so in general we want to
look at second derivatives okay so now
we are getting to the real stuff so how
many second derivatives do we have
that's maybe the first thing we should
figure out well we can take the
derivative first with respect to X and
then again with respect to X okay that
gives us something we denote by partial
square F over partial x squared or F sub
X X then there's another one which is F
sub XY which means you take the
derivative with respect to X and then
with respect to Y another thing you can
do is do first derivative respect to Y
and then with respect to X that will be
F sub y X well good news these are
actually always equal to each other so
it's a fact that we will admit it's
really not very hard to check but so
these are always the same we don't need
to worry about which one we do that's
one computation that we won't need to do
we can save bit of effort and then we
have the last one namely the second
partial with respect to Y and Y absurd
YY okay so we have three orphan
so
what does the second derivative test say
it says say that you have a critical
point x0 y0 of a function of two
variables F and then let's compute the
partial derivatives so let let's call
capital A the second derivative with
respect to X let's call capital B the
second derivative with respect to X and
Y and C equals F sub YY at this point
okay so these are just numbers because
we first compute the second derivative
and then we plug in the values of x and
y at the critical point so this will
just be numbers and now what we do is we
look at the quantity a C minus B squared
I am NOT forgetting a 4 you will see why
very soon
so if AC minus B squared is positive
then there's two sub cases if a is
positive then it's a local minimum
the second case so still if AC minus B
squared is positive but a is negative
then it's going to be a local maximum
and if AC minus B squared is negative
then it's a saddle point and finally if
AC minus B squared is zero then we
actually cannot conclude we don't know
whether it's going to be a minimum
maximum or saddle
we know it's degenerate in some way but
we don't know what type of point it is
okay so that's actually what you need to
remember if you're you know formula
oriented that's all you need to remember
about today but let's try to understand
why you know how this comes out of what
we had there okay so I think maybe I
actually want to keep so maybe I want to
keep this middle board because it
actually has you know the recipe that we
found before for the quadratic function
so let me move directly over there and
try to relate our old recipe with a new
one
you're easily amused
okay so so first let's check that these
two things say the same thing in the
special case that we were looking at
okay so let's verify in the special case
where the function was a x squared plus
bx y plus c y squared so well what is
the second derivative with respect to X
and X if I take the second derivative
respect to X and X so first I want to
take maybe the derivative respect to X
but first let's take just the first
partial W sub X that will be 2 ax plus B
Y right
so W sub xx will be well let's take the
path with respect to X again that's 2a w
sub XY I take the partial with respect
to Y I will get B okay now we need also
the partial with respect to Y so W sub y
is 3 X plus 2 CY
in case you don't believe what I told
you about the mixed partials W sub y X
well you can check and it's again B so
they are indeed the same thing and W sub
YY will be 2 C so if we now look at this
quantities that tells us well big a is
too little a Big B is little B big C is
too little C so AC minus B squared is
what we used to call for little AC minus
B squared
okay
so now you can compare the cases well
they're not listed in the same order
just to make it you know harder but so
we say it first
if so the saddle case is when AC minus B
squared in big letters is negative
that's the same as for AC minus B
squared in lower case is negative the
case where capital AC minus B Square is
positive local min and local max
corresponds to this one and the case
where we can't conclude was what used to
be the degenerate one okay so at least
we don't seem to have messed up when
copying the formula now why does that
work marginally than that well the
answer to that is again Taylor
approximation
okay so let me just do here quadratic
approximation so what are the
approximations tells me the following
thing it tells me if I have a function f
of X Y and I want to understand the
change in F when I change x and y a
little bit well there's the first order
terms as the linear terms but by now you
should know and be comfortable with
that's f sub x times the change in X
then there's F sub y times the change in
Y okay that's the starting point but now
of course if x and y so if we are the
critical point then that's going to be
zero at the critical point so that turn
actually goes away and that's also zero
at the critical point so that term also
goes away
okay so linear approximation is really
no good we need more terms so what are
the next terms well the next terms are
quadratic terms and so I mean if you
remember the Taylor formula for a
function of a single variable
there was the derivative times X minus
x0 plus one half of the second
derivative times X minus x0 squared and
see this side here is really Theta
approximation in one variable looking
only at X but of course we also have
comes involving Y n terms involving
simultaneously x and y and these terms
are f of XY times change in x times
change in Y plus 1/2 of FY y times y
minus y0 squared there's no 1/2 in the
middle because in fact you would have
two terms one for XY one for YX but they
are the same
and then if you want to continue there's
actually cubic terms involving the third
derivatives and so on but we are not
actually looking at them and so now when
we do this approximation well the type
of critical point remains the same when
we replace the function by this
approximation and so we can apply the
argument that we used to deduce things
in the quadratic case in fact we can it
still works in the general case using
this approximation formula
so the general case reduces to the
poetic case and now you see actually why
well here you see again how this
coefficient which we use to call little
a is also 1/2 of capital a and same here
this coefficient is what we call capital
B or little B and this coefficient here
is what we called little C or 1/2 of
capital C and then when you replace
things in to the various cases that we
had here you end up with the second
derivative test so what about the what
about the degenerate case why can't we
just say well it's going to be a
degenerate critical point so the reason
is that this approximation formula is
reasonable only if we higher order terms
are negligible okay so in fact secretly
there's more terms this is only an
approximation there will be terms
involving third derivatives and maybe
even beyond that and so in the non
degenerate case they don't actually
matter because the shape of a function
the shape of a graph is actually
determined by the quadratic terms but in
the degenerate case see if I start with
this and I add something even very very
small along the y-axis then that can
that can be enough to bend this very
slightly up or slightly down and turn my
the generate point into either a minimum
or a saddle point and I won't be able to
tell until I go further in the list of
derivatives so
in the degenerate case what actually
happens depends on the higher order
derivatives so we need to analyze things
more carefully while we are not going to
bother with that in this class so we'll
just say well we cannot conclude okay I
mean you have to realize that in real
life you know you have to be extremely
unlucky for this quantity to end up
being exactly zero well if that happens
then what you should do is maybe try by
inspection see there's a good reason why
the function should always be positive
or always be negative or something or
you know plot it on a computer and see
what happens but otherwise we can
conclude ok so let's do let's do an
example so probably we should leave this
on so that we still have the test with
us
and instead okay so I'll do my example
here
okay so just an example let's say I look
at f of X y equals x plus y plus 1 over
x y where x and y are positive so I'm
looking only at the first quadrant okay
I mean I'm doing this because I don't
want this denominator to become 0 so I'm
just looking at that situation so let's
look first for so the question will be
what are the minimum and the maximum of
this function so the first thing we
should do to handle two hands to answer
this question is look for critical
points okay so for that we have to
compute the first derivatives
okay so f sub x is 1 minus 1 over x
squared Y okay take the derivative of 1
over X but negative 1 over x squared and
we want to set that equal to 0 and F sub
y is 1 minus 1 over XY squared and we
want to set that equal to 0 so what are
the equations we have to solve
well I guess x squared y equals one I
mean if I get this you know they move
this guy over here i get one over x
squared y plus one that's x squared y
equals one and x y squared equals one
what do you get by comparing these two
well x and y should both be okay so yeah
I agree with you that one and one is a
solution why is it the only one so first
if I divide this one by that one I get x
over y equals one so that tells me x
equals y and then if x equals y then if
I put that into here it will give me y
cubed equals one which tells me y equals
1 and therefore x equals one as well
okay so there's only one solution
there's only one critical point which is
going to be 1 comma 1 okay so now here's
where you do a bit of work
what do you think of that critical point
okay I see some valid votes I see some I
see a lot of people answering for that
seems to suggest that maybe
well you haven't computed the second
derivative yet
yes I see someone giving the correct
answer I see some people not giving
quite big items I see more and more
correct answers okay so let's see to
figure out what type of point it is we
should compute the second partial
derivatives okay
so f sub xx is what do we get when we
take the derivative of this with respect
to X 2 over X cubed Y ok so at our point
a will be 2 F sub XY will be 1 over x
squared Y squared so B will be 1 and F
sub YY is going to be 1 no 2 over X Y
cubed so C will be 2 and so that tells
us well a C minus B squared is 4 minus 1
so you should probably use a different
blackboard for that
AC minus B squared is two times two
minus one squared is three is positive
that tells us we are either a local
minimum or a local maximum and a is
positive so it's a local minimum and in
fact we can check it's the global
minimum what about the maximum well the
maximum is not actually at a critical
point it's on the boundary or at
infinity C so we have we to check what
happens when x and y go to zero or go to
infinity
well if that happens if X or Y goes to
infinity then the function goes to
infinity also if X or Y goes to zero
when one of the X Y goes to infinity so
the maximum well the function goes to
infinity when X goes to infinity or Y
goes to infinity or x + y go to zero so
it's not at a critical point okay so in
general we have to check both the
critical points and the boundaries to
decide what happens okay
the end have a nice weekend